[Música]
durante la Cumbre de la comunidad de los
estados latinoamericanos y del Caribe la
celac que se realizó en enero en Buenos
Aires Argentina y Brasil abrieron de
nuevo la discusión sobre un proyecto de
moneda latinoamericana que primero sería
compartida por estos dos países sin
embargo no nos queda claro Qué
instrumentos se usaría para lograr un
cambio en pro de fortalecer la región y
no depender del dólar para aclarar esas
posibilidades en torno al tema nos
acompaña aribel Contreras Suárez
analista de asuntos globales y
coordinadora de la licenciatura de
negocios globales de la Universidad
iberoamericana de Ciudad de México en el
estudio también mi compañero Juan Pablo
lucumi Juan Pablo gracias Y bueno pues a
liderar esta entrevista para entender
qué es lo que tiene que ver con la
moneda suramericana aribel gracias a
usted al control muy buenos días Ángela
y un gusto poder estar aquí contigo y
con Juan Pablo Buenos días Pues nos
gustaría empezar hablando acerca de Pues
el tema de la moral comparándolo con
Europa porque pues es un buen referente
para América para que América la tiene
que hipotéticamente adopte un proyecto
de moneda única eso teniendo en cuenta
de que pues la estructura de la Unión
Europea permite la creación de políticas
a largo plazo a plazo mientras los
gobiernos de latinoamérica son un poco
cambiantes y Incluso se dice que ahora
con la ola de la izquierda puede que
tengan como un revés para bolas de
derecha en próximos gobiernos no habría
continuidad del proyecto incluso y
volvería a pasar como ha sucedido en
ocasiones que pues el proyecto
básicamente no avanza
Así es Juan Pablo el gran referente pues
es la creación del euro sin embargo
debemos de recordar que para que la
Unión Europea llegara a esta moneda
única tuvieron que pasar más de cinco
décadas desde aquel primer intento
cuando se creó la comunidad de Carbón y
el acero fueron largas negociaciones
intentar homogeneizar las economías las
políticas monetarias crear un Banco
Central europeo y todo un sistema donde
pudieran estar los bancos de cada nación
unificados hoy cuando vemos que se pone
sobre la mesa esta propuesta no debemos
de olvidar Juan Pablo que desde el año
2007 hubo Chávez quería crear la moneda
única latinoamericana la cual en su
momento él nombró sucre hoy ante esta
posibilidad de que abrieron las cartas
sobre la mesa el presidente argentino
con el brasileño donde dicen que ahora
la apuesta es hacia el sur es decir una
moneda que pudiera abarcar pues la
mayoría de los países de la región de
América Latina y el Caribe pues se abren
muchas dudas hay muchísimos
cuestionamientos como tú bien lo decías
y en realidad América Latina está lista
para poder hablar de una moneda única
cuando ni siquiera hay una verdadera
integración y cuando hay una gran
división política donde pareciera que
hay muchas Américas latinas al interior
de esta propia región con este contexto
que usted nos entrega a nivel pues vamos
a hablar de si tenemos realmente como
región la capacidad de crear una moneda
única porque justamente nos dieron un
ejemplo en la celada que los presidentes
de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y
de Argentina Alberto Fernández buscando
una primera Alianza pero es que el
propio Fernández dijo que no tiene claro
cómo sería esa implementación cómo sería
ese proceso Cuáles son esas condiciones
que tendríamos que reunir como
continente
Así es Ángela y de entrada yo creo que
habría que destacar que Argentina tiene
la economía más frágil de toda la región
Argentina ya llegó una inflación de tres
dígitos tiene una deuda pública
específicamente con el Banco Mundial y
el fondo monetario internacional más
grande de toda la región entonces me
parece que la idea debería de surgir de
otra nación que pueda contar con una
estabilidad económica para poder tan
siquiera plantearlo es decir Quién
ganaría más en esta situación sería
Argentina y quien estaría perdiendo más
sería Brasil entonces Creo yo que antes
de que sigan hablando de esta propuesta
de una moneda única Me parece que
primero hay que tratar de poner en orden
una serie de estructuras y y de
instituciones requeridas para Después de
varias décadas poder llegar a una moneda
está América Latina Caribe afectadísima
por la pandemia se vive una crisis
estacionaria a la luz también pues de la
guerra en Ucrania además de grandes
afectaciones que hemos visto en esta
polarización política El Avance de las
izquierdas manifestaciones sociales en
diferentes coordenadas de la región y
por lo tanto Me parece que hoy la primer
conversación que se debe de poner sobre
la mesa no es la moneda única sino
avanzar en una verdadera integración lo
vimos apenas la semana pasada Ángela que
inclusive tú estuviste dando cobertura
en tu noticiero de la celac esta cumbre
de la comunidad de Estados
centroamericanos y el Caribe donde hubo
dimes diretes y quedó muy claro y quedó
en evidencia en los reflectores
Internacionales que lo que menos hay es
integración cada país cada gobierno va
para sus propios lados y será
verdaderamente
un laberinto que se pudiera llegar a
unificar criterios para poder poner
sobre la mesa
inclusive como lo dijo Hasta el
mandatario venezolano
él ya quiere hablar de criptodivisas al
interior de la moneda única entiendo que
el objetivo Angela es dejar de depender
del euro Perdón del dólar sin embargo
esta gran dependencia política económica
y comercial que se tiene con Estados
Unidos
es abismal Entonces aunque china ha
avanzado en ser el primer socio o
segundo socio comercial de la mayoría de
los países hablar de esta moneda única
me parece todavía un sueño a nivel y
precisamente Nos gustaría hablar de esos
requisitos usted los mencionaba porque
la moneda entraría primero Pues a Brasil
y Argentina pero son dos de los países
que básicamente están de Polo a Polo en
tema de inflación Argentina alcanzando
un 94,8% anual ahora en enero y Brasil
con una de las más bajas o sea Argentina
con una de las más altas obviando esto a
Venezuela y Brasil con alas más bajas
uno de los requisitos se ha dicho que es
un poco como liberar ese nivel de
inflación pero también el tema de los
bancos centrales cada Banco Central de
cada país toma una decisión diferente
para hacerle pues frente a la inflación
Cuáles serían esos requisitos entonces
de la moneda
me encanta tu planteamiento Juan Pablo
porque de entrada Tenemos que tener muy
claro que Brasil no puede ser el
salvavidas de Argentina ni de ningún
país Lula da Silva enfrenta verdaderos
problemas en su propia agenda doméstica
cada país ahorita se está enfrentando
diferentes problemáticas al interior
Pues de su propia agenda la propuesta o
La Apuesta que está haciendo Alberto
Fernández es intentar ver de qué manera
tiene como lo dije un salvavidas porque
no olvidemos que Argentina este año
tiene elecciones presidenciales entonces
aquí cuando ya se politiza el tema pues
ya empezamos mal Qué requisitos se
requieren Pues de entrada por supuesto
tratar de armonizar los sistemas
bancarios centrales
avanzar a crear un Banco Central
latinoamericano donde cada país esté
dispuesto Hasta cierto punto entender
que habrá que en cuestiones de soberanía
monetaria pero al mismo tiempo tendrá
que contar con las reservas
internacionales de su propia divisa para
dar sustento a lo que vendría siendo una
moneda es decir es muy complicado hoy
por hoy decir me voy a deslindar del
dólar pero tampoco el camino Juan Pablo
sería dolarizarnos es decir no podemos
anclarnos a la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos sino que aquí la apuesta
sería como anclarnos a un banco que
ahorita no existe Y que además se
requieren diferentes fases la Unión
Europea lo logró con Unión con el euro a
través de tres fases que duró diez años
entonces Y eso que son economías un
poquito más cerrada La Brecha Hoy hay
una gran disparidad económica en la
región entonces Creo yo que esta apuesta
tendría que ser a muy largo plazo contar
con diferentes proyectos Pero antes de
llegar a Eso me parece que algo vital
será que se tiene que el peor cáncer de
la región que es la corrupción donde ya
el día de antier sabíamos que
transparencia internacional destacó como
América Latina y el Caribe es la región
que más ha avanzado en cuestión de
corrupción teniendo corrupción no
podemos hablar de una estructura mínima
para dar la arquitectura financiera a
avanzar a los requisitos mínimos de la
creación de una moneda única
latinoamericana muy rápidamente aribel
Cuáles son los gobiernos que ya han
demostrado el interés en esta moneda
común México por ejemplo de plano dijo
que no
Así es Ángela al presidente mexicano Ya
dijo que definitivamente no que la
apuesta es a la integración pero vemos
Que Colombia coquetea con esta propuesta
Bolivia
posiblemente se pueda sumar lo mismo A
lo mejor
lo que es Uruguay Paraguay se sumen
porque no olvidemos que Brasil Argentina
Paraguay y Uruguay conforman el mercado
común del sur pero vemos que más bien
Aquí se están sumando más por ideología
política que por afinidad de Propuesta
económica Angela Así que Creo yo que
aunque se sumen en intención Ya en la
realidad pues únicamente estará
Argentina y puede ser que argentina se
quede solo en esta propuesta Ángela